Meet the most audacious granddads this side
of a Sunday roast.
The so called “grandpa gang” pulled off
the largest burglary in English history in
April 2015.
The group of four men robbed a safety deposit
building in the world famous Hatton Garden
area of London – well known for its jewelry
and diamond stores.
The gang hobbled away with £14 million worth
of diamonds, jewelry and cash.
But let’s not all get too excited, these
weren’t your average grandpas, who got overly
frustrated at bingo and decided to plan a
grand larceny out of the blue.
Every member of the gang was a seasoned criminal
who had a long rap list of armed robberies
between them.
Hey, with life expectancy’s rising along
with the retirement age, you can’t blame
them for not wanting to hang it up just yet.
The ringleader and mastermind of the plot
is a man codenamed “Basil” – the group
originally settled on Mr. Pink, but he was
having none of that.
Other members of the group were nicknamed
“Mr. Ginger, Mr. Strong, Mr. Montana, The
Gent, The Tall Man and The Old Man”.
This sounds like a movie just waiting to happen.
It was a well orchestrated, ambitious and
daring plan, all thought up by a group of
cockney granddads in a pub in Islington, seriously
thought it’s like the cast of Snatch have
returned for a reunion 30 years later.
The youngest of the group was 48 years-old,
whilst the rest where in their 50s, 60s and
70s, the eldest being ringleader Brian Reader
at 76.
Better yet, Brian Reader actually used his
senior citizen’s buss pass to get to the
scene of the crime.
You’ve got to admire these gent’s tenacity.
It’s believed eleven men where involved
in the planning of the burglary, but only
four of the men actually carried out the theft,
those four also happened to be the eldest
and most experienced of the group.
So how did they do it?
Well it was no small feat, the audacious plan
was three years in the making.
To start, the burglary was perfectly timed
to take place on the long Easter weekend,
a four-day holiday in the UK.
This gave them four full days to perform the
theft when they knew the safety deposit boxes
would not be manned.
The main man, Basil, who’s identity is still
unknown, was an insider who the police believed
either worked at or had strong connections
with Hatton Garden Safe Deposit LTD, for months
or even years before the robbery took place.
The four men approached the building disguised
as garbage collector’s pushing wheelie bins,
the bins of course having a double use, as
they were also used to transport the stolen
goods out of the building afterwards.
The gang then used Basil’s insider knowledge
to enter the building via the elevator shaft,
they then climbed down to the basement and
drilled through the thick concrete wall of
the underground vault using an industrial
diamond-tipped power drill.
And then they robbed the vault!
No… not quite, remember, this was a sophisticated,
elderly gentleman’s caper, this wasn’t
a smash and grab and they’re certainly not
in the hood.
So they took their sweet time, after a full
day of drilling the men were too exhausted
to carry on and were foiled by a metal cabinet
inside the vault which they couldn’t shift.
So they all went home for a cuppa and a crossword
presumably, then returned the next day, entered
the vault and stole 73 deposit boxes containing
£14 million worth of fine gemstones and luxury
goods.
But the escapade wasn’t without its blunders.
The daring old gents actually triggered the
alarm during the first day of the robbery.
So surely that was game over?
No, security guards came but declared it was
a false alarm and left.
“Bloody ‘ell guv’nor that was a close
one”, we can only imagine the gang remarked
before continuing along their merry way.
This was a proper old-school caper.
The gang used walkie-talkies to communicate
to avoid being tracked by the police.
You won’t find this lot using burners and
fancy internet VPNs.
So what became of this bunch of old-timers?
Well the gang may have gotten away with many
robberies in the past, but their old age must
have caught up to them as they left a few
clues with eventually led to the arrest of
all but one individual involved in the robbery.
One of the police detective’s biggest clues
was that gang member Daniel Jones bought a
hydraulic pump in a specialist hardware shop
in Twickenham, 15 miles from the scene of
the crime.
But the silly bugger only went and gave his
real name and address to the sales assistant.
All-in-all the gang may have just been a bit
out of their depth and out of practice with
all the new fangled technology and techniques
the police now use to track down criminals.
They were definitely trying to brush up on
it all as the police found a “Forensics
for Dummies” book in one of the men’s
apartments.
You just couldn’t make this stuff up.
So who was the one man that did get away?
It was of course the infamous, the incredible,
the main man at the heart of it all, “Basil”.
Whilst all his cohorts are now serving time,
to this day, the police still have no idea
as to the identity of whereabouts of Basil,
what they do know is that wherever he is,
he has a cool £10 million worth of diamonds
on him.
Rumour has it he used his new found wealth
to start a hotel in Torquay with his wife
Sybil.
I guess we’ll never know.